[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
miron savim il marque avec le temps
trahi sa chute comme dans les fours ou
tendance en autonome ria et
rien rien c'est mon équilibre
en attendant que sol
la clôture
rés mais face à l'affairé
ne vois tu pas nos corps partir à la
dérive si on paie rien rien rien toi
tu veux qu'on sorte
le prix
est ce moi je dire
fini
je sais pas
[Musique]
marseille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
formé à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
ces fleurons syrie je m'offre plus de
rose hill à d'une autre dans ton lit
autant
[Musique]
c'est comme la peur du vide aucun de
nous ne lâche par instinct de survie
mais face à la faim et à la fuite
je vois déjà six mois et nous visons si
bien le
toi tu me dis que plus rien n'a de sens
tu
goosen encore une énième chance
dans
les peaux meilleur
il
oui
[Musique]
rien
sa mère
m
[Musique]
thomas je fais du mieux que nous le
problème
[Musique]
non je te dis que c'est secondaire
qu attend des actes ça m'aidait une
rancoeur je me prépare à l'impact en
skiff à cent à l'heure
je pense tu m'aimes réparé si j'étais
plastie tueur sans toi je peux pas mais
quand tu pleures je garde mon armure pas
tendre pour notre mariage quittant sens
où ce gros orage en est pas comme ma vie
des miennes jusqu'au grand voyage nous
refaire j'arriverai page et pour avoir
une fierté malsaine
je sais
toulouse
m
et
[Musique]
et mon amour naît ça vire
c'est mon se détruit on casse on
reconstruit mais bref ça ne bouge pas et
ton sourire n'a pas pris ce serait la
guerre à celui
de ma mère mon amour le sommet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
quoi
bon
oh